THIS IS "THE FIVE."
NEW DEVELOPMENTS ON THE
REPUBLICAN PUSH FOR
INVESTIGATION OF ALLEGED FISA
ABUSES BY THE FBI AND D.O.J. IN
RUSSIA PROBE.
THE INTERNATIONAL WATCHDOG AT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WILL
EXAMINE ACCUSATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT.
THE FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ADVISER CARTER PAGE.
MICHAEL HOROWITZ IS
INVESTIGATING AT THE REQUEST OF
THE JEFF SESSIONS.
JUDGE NAPOLITANO THINKS HE WILL
FIND WRONG DOING.
>> I BELIEVE THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL WILL FIND A TREASURE
TROVE NOT JUST McCABE AND
COMPANY, THAT IS THE MOST SEEM
VIOLATION -- THE VICTIM IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE WAS A CANDIDATE AND
PRESIDENT-ELECT AT THE TIME.
HE WILL FIND A TREASURE TROVE OF
ABUSES GOING TO FISA GETTING
WARRANTS.
>> NOBODY HAS ACTUALLY NUNES
ADMITTED HE HASN'T READ THE
DOCUMENTS.
MICHAEL HOROWITZ IS THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AT THE D.O.J.
HE IS GOING TO LOOK INTO THIS.
HE'S GOT A LOT ON HIS PLATE TO
INVESTIGATE.
HAS CONFIDENCE OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL SESSIONS AS WELL AS
MEMBERS OF THE HILL ON THE
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK ON THE
MOST CRITICAL ISSUES.
>> YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE IN
TERMS OF WHO'S MAKING THE
REQUEST, WHAT EVIDENCE THEY'RE
RELYING ON TO SUBSTANTIATE THESE
CLAIMS.
WE HAVE TO GIVE HIM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO THROUGH IT.
OTHERWISE THE SPECULATION IN
TERMS OF WHAT KIND OF VIOLATIONS
ETCETERA THAT THEY MIGHT
UNCOVERED.  I'M INTERESTED WHO
IS GETTING THE EVIDENCE AND WHAT
SOURCES.
WE'VE SEEN SOME ABUSES IN THE
PAST IN TERMS OF INFORMATION
THAT WAS PROPER THAT WASN'T
ACCURATE, THAT WASN'T VERIFIED.
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
CHECK OUT IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY
MIGHT BE LOOKING FOR
>> THEY'RE ALL LOOK INTO THOSE
THINGS.
THERE'S A TON OF ACCUSATIONS.
PART OF THIS COMES FROM THE TEXT
MESSAGES FROM THE FBI AGENTS WHO
WAS HAVING AFFAIR.
THERE WAS COORDINATION BETWEEN
THE WHITE HOUSE AND FBI.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
INDEPENDENT THAN THAT, THIS WAS
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
>> NOT JUST THE OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE BUT THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE,
THE FBI, D.O.J., HARRY REED, CIA
AND HILLARY CLINTON.
IF YOU JUST TAKE IT FROM THE
BEGINNING, HILLARY PAID FOR THE
FAKE DOSSIER FILLED WITH RUSSIAN
LIES.
THEY HAVE YOU HAVE A HILLARY
DONOR WHO SENT FBI THE TIP ABOUT
PAPADOPOULOS.
THESE FBI AGENTS OPENED UP THE
INVESTIGATION.
THEN, JOHN BRANNAN THE CIA
DIRECTOR UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
BRIEFS HARRY REED ABOUT IT.
AT THE SAME TIME OBAMA CHIEF OF
STAFF AT THE WHITE HOUSE, HAD
BEEN TALKING BRIEFED BY THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE DIVISION OF
THE FBI ABOUT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
INVESTIGATION AND FROM WHAT WE
BELIEVE HE WAS URGING IT TO MOVE
FORWARD.
THE BRIEFING FROM BRANNAN TO
REID LEAKED AND WOUND UP IN THE
ISIKOFF ARTICLE.
IT WAS USED AS A JUSTIFICATION
FOR THE WARRANTLESS SPYING ON
CARTER PAGE.
IT'S FUNNY, CARTER PAGE NEVER
BEEN CHARGED WITH A CRIME AND
WAS FBI INFORMANT FOR MANY YEARS
WAS FBI INFORMANT FOR MANY YEAR
YEARS.
JAMES COMEY TAKES THE
INFORMATION.
IT'S ALL VERIFIED AND ISIKOFF
ARTICLE.
AS THIS IS ALL HAPPENING THE FBI
AGENTS TEXT AND THEY SAY, HERE
WE GO.
TO THE ALLEGATION IS THAT THEY
HAVE THROUGH ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE, LAID THE GROUND WORK AND
LAID THE LEGITIMACY FOR THE
SURVEILLANCE ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
AFTER TRUMP'S ELECTED, JAMES
COMEY BRIEFS THE PRESIDENT ON
THE DOSSIER AND THAT SAME DAY,
CIA DIRECTOR UNDER OBAMA BEEN
THAN LEAKS THE INFORMATION TO
CNN.
WHEN ALL THESE INVESTIGATORS
START ASKING FOR DOCUMENTATION,
THEY GET STONEWALLED BY THE FBI
AND THE D.O.J.
THE COORDINATE NATION IS
AMAZING.
IF ONLY REPUBLICANS COULD
COORDINATED EFFECTIVELY AS THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS STEVE
BANNON SAID BEFORE HE LEFT, HOW
CAN WE COLLUDE.
>> FAIR POINT.
>> IMAGINE IF THIS KIND OF
EVIDENCE WAS PRESENTED UNDER
PRESIDENT HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT WAS AGAINST HER UNDERMINING
HER.
THE MEDIA WOULD BE IN THEIR PINK
HATS MAKING PROTEST SIGNS.
IT'S NOT.
IT'S UNDER UNDER TRUMP.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE LIKE THEM.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET HYSTERICAL.
THIS IS ONE OF THE LONGEST
DANCES IER SEEN IN POLITICS.
I CALL IT THE COLLUSION TWO
STEP.
STEP ONE IT'S A TRUMP RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, IT'S COORDINATION
AMONG OFFICIALS.
TWO STEP KEEPS GOING ON AND ON.
YOU'RE GOOD AT THIS.
I RECOMMEND WE DECLARE THIS BEEF
A TIE AND LIKE YOU IN SOCCER,
THE END OF THE GAME, 0-0.
I CAN SETTLE THIS WITH PENALTY
KICKS.
THIS IS A ZERO GAME.
JUST HAVE EACH SIDE DO PENALTY
KICKS.
WITH YOU SHOULD START EXPELLING
PEOPLE ON EACH SIDE.
>> DANA, NEWS JUST CAME IN
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS HAS
STATED THERE WILL BE NO SPECIAL
SECOND COUNSEL NEEDED.
FOR NOW.
DOESN'T MEAN IT WON'T COME
LATER.
>> THE OTHER IN ADDITION TO
THAT, THERE WAS BREAKING NEWS
THAT THE "NEW YORK TIMES" BROKE
PRESIDENT'S FORMER LAWYER HAD
APPROACHED THE LAWYERS FOR
MICHAEL FLYNN AND PAUL MANAFORT
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF A
PARDON AND JOHN DOWD SAYING,
THAT DIDN'T REALLY HAPPEN.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF SOURCES ON
IT.
OTHER THING IS, REUTERS SAYS
THERE'S ADDITIONAL INVESTIGATION
MUELLER LOOKING INTO ACTUAL
CONVERSATIONS TAKING PLACE AT
THE CONVENTION IN OHIO FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
ESPECIALLY LOOKING INTO HOW THAT
ALONG ABOUT UKRAINE GOT WATERED
DOWN SO MUCH IN THE PLATFORM.
>> WOW.
REAL NEWS.
ALL OF THIS SEEMS TO BE
STRIKING.
IT PUTS THE PRESIDENCY IN A VERY
POSITION.
IF YOU HAVE JOHN DOWD NO LONGER
THE PRESIDENT'S TOP LAWYER, BUT
JOHN DOWD REACHING OUT TO
LAWYERS FOR PAUL MANAFORT AND
MIKE FLYNN TO DISCUSS THE
POSSIBILITY OF PARDONS.
THAT'S DIRECT OBSTRUCTION OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
BECAUSE THE IDEA, MANAFORT HAS
YET TO STRIKE A DEAL AND PEOPLE
ARE WONDERING WHAT'S GOING ON
THERE.
>> ON THAT POINT, I WAS
LISTENING TO THE DAILY THIS
MORNING, ABOUT JOHN DOWD, HE
SAID, WHAT WE HAVE PARDONED THEM
FOR?
YOU CAN'T GIVE A BLANKET PARDON
FOR YOU'RE PARDONED?
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO WAIT LONG.
THEY'RE INDICTED.
YOU CAN HANG OUT THERE THE
POSSIBILITY OF A PARDON.
THEN ONCE THEY ARE INDICTED, YOU
KNOW WHAT, NO NEED TO COOPERATE.
NO NEED TO TELL YOUR TALE THAT
MIGHT BE DAMNING TO THE
PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE POWER TO
PARDON.
THE PRESIDENT'S POWER IS PRETTY
MUCH UNLIMITED WITH REGARD TO
PARDON IN THIS CASE, BECAUSE
HE'S THE ONE UNDER
INVESTIGATION, IT WOULD BE
ILLEGAL.
IT WOULD BE NOT NECESSARILY,
ILLEGAL, IT WOULD ALLOW ROBERT
MUELLER TO SAY THERE'S
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CASE
BASED ON THE BEHAVIOR OF
PRESIDENT'S LAWYER.
THE SECOND THING IS, WITH REGARD
TO UKRAINE AND THE WATERING DOWN
THE LANGUAGE AT THE CONVENTION,
AGAIN, HERE IS RUSSIA PLAYING A
ROLE POTENTIALLY IF THIS STORY
IS TRUE, THAT REALLY AGAIN,
UNDERMINES THE DEMOCRATIC'S
PROCESS.
EVEN REPUBLICANS CAN'T GET THEIR
OWN POLICY PLATFORM IN PLACE
WITHOUT RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
>> YOU CAN CHANGE A POLICY
WITHOUT INTERFERENCE.
>> NOW THE POLICY WITH REGARD TO
UKRAINE IS MUCH TOUGHER THAN IT
WAS UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
WE SOLD THEM MISSILES AND HARD
ARMS WHERE OBAMA WAS GIVING THEM
FOOD.
>> YOU FORGET THAT RUSSIA WAS
UPSET WE WERE PUTTING
ANTI-MISSILE DEVICES IN POLAND
AND OTHER PLACES THERE.